nspro Nplastination phone
st Drive My Car
[Clapping]
[Music]
Sanki Layer March A
computer and
ah ah ah ah I'll give you this
Film Independent
Side Show
Janspel 6
Warner Media
150 Company
mature
Thank you for coming
sore to do search Seed
js 4 medarot nf
Display Arm
Axina Mini This time I made it to America for the first time in my life
astar Sumo
Poster 6 d 5 days miy
I think the
director Ryusuke Hamaguchi also wanted to stand
here and receive this award.
I would like to thank him and the cast with the master on behalf of him
.
Jack  ask who
do
rear Cass-style
Distiler
Drive My Car Wow, it
's a story of those souls who lose their loved ones and regain their lives through a long way.
I found a little light
behind a long tunnel and left it too long
voodoo ah ah
ah Thank you
again for choosing this long and long healing path of
the great artist that the film performance pen training has produced
I
'm really grateful to be able to join the line
, and I hope that art will continue to be the North Pole of our soul
. Copyright That Cut My
Car Today's Bucks 1
Lumber
[Clapping]
Ah ah ah
so pen type and place of death fight